ma la ragazzi e bambini dove sono
episodi oggi e domenica quindi
indovinate cosa facciamo
venerdì 13 non è vero effettivamente
ragazzi dall'ultima dome e il nice day
shine niente bella un'ottima partenza
siamo in famiglia però
ma cosa vero one man iron nota va bè
fermi fermi il caso succedendo
by come ma posso anche muovermi ma ad
ora era allora un senso ma la vaschetta
ormai la partenza adesiva bisognasse
tutt'altro livello questo no stavo
dicendo che essendo domenica oggi volevo
fare nei livelli abbastanza allegri
perché questo video non si registrano
proprio di domenica però a quanto pare a
quanto pare questa quarantena ha fatto
malissimo a duke e il padre uk a posto
tutto a posto ragazzi andiamo avanti
ancora rotoliamo ancora un pò che ti
bella copertina del video ce l'abbiamo
volendo potevi tappare il buco è
esattamente con te stesso però fa niente
ditemi se questo non è uno dei video
riveli up che io abbia mai fatto sue più
vi sarà un senso rotoliamo e basta farci
tornare piatti e mia adesso è vietato
cicero è lui ma spiegate mills thanks
for playing
questo livello della vita in una pro
altro livello all'infuori di questo
bellissimo the next rachman fire scout
ragazzi ultimamente da un po che non ne
faccio di serie quindi devo riuscire a
fare qualcosa di decente soprattutto
quando si tratta di multicolor chi è chi
era cosa a qui nel senso devo finirla
beh grazie avevo intuito di sicuro non
mi volevo buttare nel vuoto aiuto parco
demonio che comunque hanno tutti sta
strutture ultimamente i rokes un inglese
ci fate caso perfetto e quindi oddio
dove centrale il buco cos'è aiuto ma dai
sono stupidi e una mucca che però fa sul
traguardo non avevo capito ma perché mi
sembrava una roba mi sembra tipo di cose
le tiri a freccette quindi ho detto
vabbè sarà quello traguardo fatto strano
invece non era il traguardo quello hub è
ottimo non fatemi pensare con il mio
cervello ragazzi pensate col vostro e
datemi la mano poi sono solo una mera mi
scusi ma un fed
ok perfetto va fatta ma questa volta non
era così di non è stato così difficile
9 cos'è una ruota che
tutto sto casino per poi arrivare alla
fine che mancava un secondo se vuoi
riesco amori dei livelli di scoprire
sempre un secondo prima che il che
incredibile poi scelti spies
vuol dire che dal paracadute non è vero
no vabbè geniale come mai
ecco cosa è successo come voi ragazzi di
verità parco lemonia come mai ragazzi
livelli di e quindi sono così belli oggi
ma che è così
cosa vi siete fumati settimana porca
vacca e sono anche abbastanza difficili
non è nemmeno facile
non riesco è veramente difficile da
controllare sta a fare mi sembra giorgio
sembra cagata non lo è ma anzi che sarà
volto non ottima spina di giu sono molto
ma dai ma dai
e vabbè non rimorchio più le ragazze
come rimorchiava una volta sotto i
ragazzi una volta una tipa anno ha
scritto su facebook ma scritto guarda mi
piace un sacco di video di è che visse
usciamo insieme e io ho detto guarda
sarebbe tipo un impossible
questa è buona regola queste qua sono
dritto
proprio a rapture poi 61 fakes l'avete
anche di buona fortuna mortale a chi sta
aiutando nel mortale schifoso
c'era un tale non hanno visto di tutto
il lavoro visto il tavolo e non sa
ancora e non muoio e meno male che l'ho
detto però ti sta bene questa azione
come vestito non ho bellissima sta roba
il fatto non avrà visto tavolo è stato
incredibile però no ma continuano io
continuo a concentrarvi sugli anziani a
non vedere gli oggetti che ho davanti
e veramente triste sta cosa celo celo
aiuto c'è un cesso
sono vivo madonna è stato veramente
difficile avuto l'ansia mille
l'importante farcela un po come nelle
qui i primi appuntamenti fultz boa
quella come a gigi gigi era dentro era
dentro non vale non lo parata da
ripararla era dentro non so se s'è visto
gg avrei preferito tirarlo il calcio
però non fa niente swatch red vari set è
che però non era svolto a machete
machete truce records tik tok and see
things this is fun mihc sarandì sfiga
tic toc di hatemaj speso fritz a quello
non me lo puoi mai fare lui ha chiamato
il computer e non l'ho ucciso
però vi rendete conto che avete messo
veramente poche spade si vero quel tic
toc acqua e poi schiacciare per averti
spazio kay e non lo sapevo questo a te
darò in stile di george lewis thank you
for the music no mancato che anch'io
farò dei musei ha poi fatto
oggi i livelli incredibili comunque non
se la sia successo oggi
ma è jason jason bourne ed altro e non
lo shock jason in rosa però sta roba
stai quindi l'ho saltato proprio tanto
non lo puoi uccidere leatherface
bellissimo quindi a stephanie nominare
score di scream lo sapevo ma spesso lo
sapevo lo sapevo
michael myers chucky che sfiga michael
myers e la pro loco
no neanche ucciso perché ora ragazzi
quattro su cinque la zecca di credibile
che è maestro dell'horror proprio per
saper league per conoscerli tutti pro
perché ciò più conosco più personaggi
horror che amici nella mia vita quindi
figure ei charlie watts
chi è che botta mi spiace c'è chi non
volevo farti così male per ora è michael
myers mi ammazzo super michael myers
veramente difficile superare michael
myers madonna che chi l'ho fatto a jason
con un machete attaccato alla schiena
proseguo perchè non ho paura
prenditi questo poco che te lo regalo io
sono riuscendole peggio trash atteso
liver però veramente figo gli ata non
succede niente semplicemente succedono
situazioni tipo questa ti devi togliere
perfetto tutto a posto
[Applauso]
sono atterrato sulla tua faccia non so
neanche come ho fatto
ragazzi stanno succede europee
incredibili in un livello veramente
monotono il che è veramente mi fa capire
quanta skilo raggiunti sto gioco negli
anni e ga space uk and ora temi
ok ero quasi morto e ciechi whatsapp mi
sono partite tutte le gambe senza un
apparente motivo manca michael myers
vediamo se riuscirà a farmi fuori anche
stavolta è michael mayer lo stimato a
gioca a yara
non riesco ucciderlo fa niente ok a
posto con sistemato pure michael myers
saranno sta dando senza meta con il mio
poco freddy krueger che neanche ucciso
effettivamente mancavano 9 a caso lui
praticamente questi cacchio ce ne sono
ok madonna fatta una parata incredibile
freddy krueger super anche freddy
krueger l'ohr face stato io st cazzola
in braccio va bene c'è soffiava un po
per i boss aiuto
il boss è veramente difficile ora
ragazzi non me ne vado io non me ne vado
finché non ho finito è veramente
difficile era solo enigmista comunque
boss
vediamo se riesco a superare almeno saw
l'enigmista veramente difficile suo
livello
per quanto sia monotono perché alla fine
stanno fermi qui non è neanche dc è
impossibile e che sono non lo so sono
tarati apposta per fare per finirci
sopra e quindi non è facile ok ok aiuto
ce l'ha fatta
l'ho saltato nel ca
ragazzi ci ho messo sei ore per questo
livello ma ne è valsa la fottutissima
pena bellissimo solleticare in the box
neon
madonna non faccio un getting the box da
6000 anni da quando ho fatto l'episodio
dedicato ai death in the box si vede che
non sei più bravo con gli addominali e
mamma mia schifo che schifo mi deludi un
sacco bravo madonna che ho fatto
poi ci sto facendo provate sul prato e
non sto capendo cosa mi prende oggi
sembra che io abbia preso tutti questi
anni di eps abbia fatto veramente un
qualcosa di utile cioè skill armi suo
gioco trova altro cioè lancio nel piede
di porco
va bene white force trend and click
questi sarebbero i piedi di porci è il
club ei solo via
[Musica]
io non so cosa ho sentito centrale per
cento passi come oggi abbiamo fatto
tutto alla pagina se riusciamo a fare
obama che non scherzavo ragazzina così
difficile suo livello
ehi ma noi come aiuto
cos'è così come successo come non ho
capito che si ama quindi non è un finale
quello è una presa per il culo
2 il finale non è un il prossimo in
questo è un poco challenge
mi dicono che siano quelli super est e
colonne non li faccio mai perché non mi
ispirano molto però questa volta sono
costretto perché l'hanno camuffato era
un imposti col prima
oddio convertino se non dico e sono
costretto a non rifarlo perché per
arrivati qua ci metto sei anni
questa ragazzi è la mia vita alla beh
comunque grazie per aver visto il video
un bacio mamma
[Musica]